[Musique]
adieu
à trop nous sommes arrivées
majeures pas trop nous sommes arrivés au
excuse-moi nounours je jouais du pipeau
je m'étais même pas rendu compte que
nous étions arrivés du pipeau du pipeau
vous étiez dans la lune
et moi je suis pressé d'aller voir mes
amis ne te fâche pas nos forums
mon seul vote prendre propos
popopopop au
cou c'est douloureux
[Musique]
j'ai dû me tromper de maisons exclure
excusez moi petit grandeur pardon madame
je me suis trompé de maison oh oui je
cherche mademoiselle nicolas et monsieur
pas preneur non monsieur oh pardon
petite grand mère
oublie-t-on madame ou holnon je m'en
veux tout de suite
[Musique]
nous sommes en bourse
l'ascenseur
ou non excusez-moi mais je n'aime pas
prendre l'ascenseur tiens tiens fermé
l'after c'est le vent
oui petit gros mais
[Musique]
les curieux cette grand mère
parce que je parle à feneu a
alors se vend
quoi encore
[Musique]
elle a une drôle de façon de relier
cette grand mère et cette fenêtre qui
est encore fait remuer tout renfort aux
savants
et le voilà le vent je le tiens
[Musique]
t'as bien attrapé ça ou alors
[Rires]
[Musique]
prenait lé que j'ai une petite coquine
et toi nicolas un petit ça sonne ballon
en dormez-vous
[Musique]
au poteau le cocan
didon la prochaine fois c'est moi qui me
déguise rahan grand père
howie vannes unique à la tombe bien
petite grand mère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
or salon soit alors et qu'y a t'il
nounours ils deviennent de plus en plus
garnements patron eut encore fait une
farce et s'il n'en faisait plus une
north je m'ennuie erreurs et bien tu
vois tu adores ça cheuvreux potro bonne
nuit les petits vous aussi vous pouvez
faire des farces à nounours il sera ravi
le mot fuck propres
[Musique]
oh